imaginez imaginer que certains aient le
pouvoir de détenir l'accès au monde des
idées des idées nouvelles
révolutionnaire capable de changer la
face du monde un pouvoir qui se
situerait à la croisée des chemins entre
la physique puisque nous avons le
bonheur d'avoir un physicien parmi nous
donc un pouvoir situé à la croisée de la
physique de la big data et de la
sociologie une sorte de pouvoirs
magiques en sommes capables de
transcender des foules et de modifier
durablement le comportement des humains
imaginons encore que certains conservent
le pouvoir ce monopole pour uniquement
le rendre accessible un petit groupe de
personnes
cette situation ne serait pas acceptable
un espoir cependant subsistent mais
avant cela pourrons-nous quelques
questions importantes comment ces idées
sont elles mises en oeuvre comme en
estelle comment sont elles fabriquées et
à partir de là comment pouvons-nous et
veut comment pour nous rêver d'unités
social de structure sociale capable
d'être à la fois créatrice productrice
et coopératives entre elles ce sont là
des questions cruciales dans le monde
d'aujourd'hui en raison du fait que
l'actualité ces dernières semaines nous
l'a rappelé la concurrence exacerbée
entre les nations les peuples mais
également enfants en raison des défis
climatiques qui nous occupe nous et les
prochaines générations en raison
également il faut le reconnaître de
l'incapacité des gouvernements à agir
notre société actuelle a pu se
développer depuis
le xviiie siècle
depuis l'avènement de l'époque des
lumières pourquoi et bien parce que les
philosophes nous ont laissé cette façon
d'appréhender le monde et qui nous ont
permis justement de pouvoir répondre à
ces questions cependant ces dernières
décennies a marqué l'avènement de
l'explosion des réseaux sociaux nous
sommes de plus en plus connectés ces
réseaux homme-machine où tout s'accélère
autour de nous et aujourd'hui nous avons
encore cette difficulté à maîtriser ces
éléments là parce qu'en fait notre façon
de voir le monde est encore fortement
imprégné de cet héritage du siècle des
lumières sur cette base et bien nous
avons pu développer une société ouverte
pluraliste où le respect de chacun
étaient étaient présents mais avec
l'explosion d'internet où les choses
vont de plus en plus vite et bien et
nous sommes bouleversés
internet a permis effectivement de une
participation plus grande mais les
choses se sont accélérées nous nous
sommes retrouvés sous un flot
d'informations
à tel point que nous avons même plus
lesquels il faut traiter en priorité les
cas il faut mettre de côté le sang bleu
le monde semblait bien perdre parfois
tout contrôle des millions de messages
sont échangées sur les réseaux sociaux
tels que twitter des krachs boursiers
s'opère à partir de ces messages là des
régimes tombent de par les messages qui
sont échangées sur ces réseaux sociaux
notre façon de comprendre et de gérer le
monde notre vision du monde est encore
gelé dit fortement teintée d l'héritage
des philosophes des lumières et oui ça
s'explique à l'époque les choses
avancent avancer beaucoup plus lentement
l'époque était beaucoup plus calme adam
smith déjà l'abbé déjà remarqué c'est le
tissu social qui guident justement cette
main invisible et pas simplement la
concurrence vous le rappeler à l'époque
dan dan smith la plupart des gens dans
les villes se connaissaient il y avait
encore cette pression sociale entre
guillemets qui faisait que les sujets et
les citoyens étaient astreints au
bénéfice de la communauté est
aujourd'hui avec la décennie dès
l'explosion des réseaux sociaux bien ses
pouvoirs le pouvoir de cette pression
sociale ce liens sociaux se sont
affaiblies et le capitalisme est bien
devient quelque peu aveugle et cette
main invisible ne joue plus son rôle
chaque fois que vous utilisez un
téléphone portable chaque fois que vous
utilisez votre carte de crédit chaque
fois que vous utilisez
votre carte de transport lorsque vous
faites des transactions en ligne eh bien
vous laisser des traces numériques vous
laissez de la data eh bien ces data sont
extrêmement utiles pour les sciences
sociales pour pouvoir étudier analyser
le comportement humain à partir du
moment où on sait pouvoir les collecter
les analyser comme je voulais dit ce qui
est intéressant c'est qu'on peut à
partir de là tisser des modèles de
manière à bien comprendre comment ils
fonctionnent effectivement les
différents groupes humains fonctionne il
ya travers lesquelles les individus
interagissent les uns avec les autres
vous connaissez le concept de physique
et de sciences sociales mais avez-vous
entendu parler de physique sociale la
physique social qu'est ce que c'est et
bien c'est un concept intéressant
discipline en réalité qui s'inspire
fortement de la physique traditionnelle
dans le sens où elle va récupérer l'idée
que le flux d'énergie
transforme occasionne un changement de
mouvements un flux d'énergie va se
traduire par fois par des changements
dans le mouvement est bien dans la
physique sociale on va s'inspirer de
cela pour comprendre comment le flux
d'informations la circulation des idées
va induire des changements dans le
comportement humain
ces comportements humains ces
changements dans les comportements
humains vont être le reflet des
interactions que nous allons avoir à
travers les différents groupes par
exemple lorsque vous estimez par exemple
que vous êtes des êtres rationnels
totalement indépendant dans vos choix de
vie dans la façon dont vous gérez vos
activités certains vont même
effectivement penser que le monde ait
fait d'individus qui
mettent en avant leurs intérêts
personnels la réalité est beaucoup plus
nuancée que cela en fait ne sont
fortement déterminés par les relations
que nous avons avec notre entourage prof
proches mais également dans les groupes
auxquels nous appartenons par exemple
ici nous avons un groupe d'étudiants de
l'unité nous avons
on peut partager également des valeurs
dont avec d'autres groupes le groupe des
ingénieurs les groupes des personnes
passionnées de sport les groupes
habitant la région de troie etc etc et
donc nous appartenons à différents
groupes ils sont complètement dissociés
parfois les uns des autres et ces
personnes là sont différentes des
personnes de notre cercle familial de
notre cercle d'amis du premier degré ce
qui est intéressant c'est que les
sciences sociales et notamment la
physique social démontre que nous sommes
autant influencé par ce premier cercle
que par les différents groupes auxquels
nous appartenons et les personnes que
nous fréquentons à travers ses
différents groupes ne sont pas forcément
des personnes que nous connaissons
personnellement ce sont pour la plupart
des simples connaissances passagère mais
nous sommes néanmoins fortement
influencé nos comportements par ces
différents groupes pourquoi parce que
nous fréquentons a su démence assidûment
ces différents groupes nous passons
beaucoup de temps que ce soit dans les
campus dans les salles de classe dont
les lieux de culture dans les
restaurants et cafétérias les bars les
cinémas alors on voulait me dire oui je
peux concevoir qu effectivement que je
peux être influencés par les les groupes
mais pour autant lorsque je suis allé au
dernier match de l'estac au stadium
j'ai vu une rixe et pas pour et ce n'est
pas pour autant que j'ai participé dans
la bagarre fait pas été influencés à ce
point de me jeter dans cette dans ce
conflit c'est vrai et je vais vous
expliquer pourquoi pour qu'un changement
durable s'opère vous devez avoir deux
critères le premier critère c'est que
vous devez être confrontés à des
changements répétitif cours et sur la
durée la deux le deuxième critère c'est
que de toute évidence ces comportements
doivent avoir un impact positif et
bénéfique pour vous prenons un exemple
lors de la pelouse lors de la pause café
si vous écoutez vos camarades si vos
collègues de travail qui prennent
habituellement du café passe subitement
à prendre du thé à consommer du thé
mais vous serez fortement inclinées vous
aurez cette inclinaison a également
consommer du thé pourquoi parce que
peut-être que certainement vous aurez
compris que le thé sera beaucoup plus
bénéfique pour votre santé que le café
première chose et deuxième chose cela va
faciliter votre acceptation votre
insertion votera stimulation dont le
groupe est donc une fois que ces deux
critères sont validées et bien vous
aurez de fortes probabilités à copier ce
nouveau changement de comportement un
autre exemple que je peux vous donner
c'est chez les singes capucins lorsque
les singes capucins décide de quitter un
endroit ils doivent identifier donc un
nouveau chemin et ce sont les singes en
tête du groupe lorsqu'ils ont identifié
justement ce nouveau chemin ou émettre
un cri les singes qui sont à l'arrière
vont copier ce signal et crier également
de manière à diffuser le message aux
autres membres du clan mais nous avons
également cette tendance à singer les
comportements qui sont bénéfiques
pourquoi le faisons nous hamma
simplement ses parts dans le cours de
notre évolution on a compris que c'était
bénéfique pour nous en termes de survie
dans le groupe et en dehors du groupe
nos chances de survie étaient
dramatiquement augmenté lorsque nous
étions intégré dans un groupe et donc
aujourd'hui eh bien on s'appuie encore
sur ce phénomène pour expliquer les
changements dans les différents groupes
humains donc des changements donc répété
sur la courte durée qui tout à la fois
bénéfique est positif un autre levier
qui est intéressant pour expliquer les
changements de comportement c'est ce
qu'on appelle les récompenses des
récompenses sociale et les récompenses
individuelles
il récompense sociale c'est-à-dire des
récompenses qui vont être prodigués
grâce à votre réseau social grâce à
votre réseau d'amis grâce aux groupes et
aux différents groupes auxquels vous
appartenez et les récompenses
individuelles ce qui met en avant votre
intérêt personnel premier et j pour
exemple en 2009 le département d'état
américain de la défense qui pour fêter
les quarante ans d'internet avait
organisé ce qu'on appelait le défi des
ballons rouges imaginez dit ballon météo
énorme de couleur rouge répartie
entièrement sur le territoire américain
le challenge était d'identifier de
l'écho de localiser ces dix ballons
rouges 4000 équipes ont répondu à ce
défi et effectivement la plupart des
équipes en présence ont choisi le
premier levier celui de favoriser la
récompense individuelle
si par exemple vous m'aider à identifier
un ballon et bien je vous propose une
récompense une équipe s'est démarqué des
4000 dhs équipe en faisant quoi en
jouant sur la carte de la récompense
social au lieu de récompenser l'individu
a identifié un ballon on allait re
récompensé l'individu à recruter des
personnes qui allaient aider
collectivement à identifier les dix
ballons qui étaient dispersés sur le
territoire américain résultat des
courses bien cette équipe a pu recruter
jusqu'à neuf millions de personnes 9
millions de personnes en utilisant
uniquement internet et les réseaux
sociaux cette équipe a remporté le
challenge en 9 heures les dix ballons
ont été localisés grâce à la récompense
sociale un autre levier intéressant à
garder en mémoire la question maintenant
est de savoir comment à partir de ces
quelques éléments que je faisais
communiqué comment on va pouvoir
organiser nos sociétés pour se diriger
vers des ensembles des structures
humaines plus harmonieuse plus
productive plus humaine en quelque sorte
pour renforcer justement ce lien social
qui s'est dessiné au fil des ans et qui
s'est accélérée avec l'avènement des
réseaux sociaux deux facteurs peuvent
contribuer à une société plus prospère
le premier est le premier facteur c'est
l'engagement l'engagement tout
simplement qu'est ce que c'est mais
c'est la faculté qu'ont les individus à
travers les différents groupes
d'interroger d'interagir dû communiquer
d'échanger des idées se sont retrouvés
comme faisons aujourd'hui est de
confronter nos des idées de les
disséquer de les déconstruire pour
pouvoir ensuite et bien les assembler
les synthétiser les rendre hybride
l'engagement deuxième facteur c'est
l'exploration l'exploration de nouvelles
idées cette capacité que nous avons tous
et toutes d'aller au devant de nouvelles
idées d'aller nous confronter au regard
de l'autre de sortir de notre zone de
confiance dose est exposée ce que nous
avons sur le coeur de partager notre
vision d'aller à la rencontre de l'autre
l'exploration donc une société prospère
idéalement à ces deux facteurs en son
sein et on peut pousser l'analyse
jusqu'à imaginer des villes qui aurait
qui pourrait combiner idéalement ces
deux facteurs l'utopie c'est la
direction dans laquelle moi je vous
propose d'aller des villes comme les
grandes métropoles ont un fort taux
d'exploration parce que effectivement on
vous savez on a la faculté de ce train
de se retrouver en face de nombreuses
personnes d horizons différents deux
groupes différents
d'origines différentes deux classes
différentes mais ce qui manque vous
l'avez compris c'est l'engagement nous
sommes tous rassemblés dans des grandes
métropoles dans des mégalopoles sans
pouvoir discuter avec notre voisin nous
prenons les transports en commun sans
même regarder faire un sourire à la
personne qui est assis juste en face de
nous une société utopiste et bien c'est
une société on pourrait effectivement
commuter se déplacer à travers des
moyens des transports en commun dans les
centres villes cosmopolites
animé on pourrait tous se rencontrer
partager et échanger des idées et donc
les sociétés doivent être capables de
justement de combiner ces différents
facteurs ce n'est pas toujours facile
c'est même un un défi mais des villes
comme zurich a réussi justement ce
défi-là ce défi là en ayant le grand
zurich entourée de petits ville où
chacune des personnes pouvaient se
déplacer facilement vers le grand zurich
avec des lieux de culture des lieux de
travail mélangez donc on a une
hybridation des lieux où les gens
pouvaient se rencontrer et échanger des
lieux où pouvaient également se
confronter aux idées des autres mais
encore une fois c'est quelque chose de
relativement difficile à mettre en place
aujourd'hui vous avez le choix vous avez
le choix effectivement de
repartir chez vous et de balayer d'un
simple regard demain ce que vous avez vu
ce soir de mépriser les idées qui vous
étaient vous ont été exposés vous avez
aussi le choix de le choix de vous
remettra au hasard pour trouver la
future bonne idée qui va changer la face
du monde ou encore pire laisser aux
autres l'opportunité de trouver cette
fameuse bonne idée de créer une nouvelle
entreprise de régler un des problèmes
importants que koné d'humanité mais vous
avez également le choix de réfléchir de
partager en commun vous idée d'aller au
devant des autres pour pouvoir réfléchir
un bien commun vous avez le choix en
m'écoutant suite à cette intervention de
passer à l'action le monde a besoin de
vous le monde a besoin de vos idées
les scellés circuler merci